[musique]
comment dire malade
mais un beat terrible parce que je ne sais pas quoi
mes gars ne partiront en aucun cas
Je ne sais pas quelle est la peine moi-même militaire
encore pire mec je m'y attendais peut-être
ne serait pas parti de là, bien, vif, si bien,
unité corporelle psychologiquement ce n'est pas
tout le monde était prêt, qu'est-ce que j'ai ressenti
le nombre de bin pris à ce qui est déjà sur galibin
mais
pas plus désolé de le battre mon frère son
qui est mort et pas un ticket de jambe est déjà
rien ne se passera parce que je sais maintenant
20e siècle et vous pouvez faire une prothèse
normal continue à vivre et
servir tranquillement donc je suis partant pour ça bien
n'a pas du tout traduit le jour pour cela de je veux
les prothèses le plus tôt sera le mieux
si possible
continuer le service
dans l'armée encore continuer la variation que je connais
que beaucoup s'en sortent mieux avec une prothèse qui
est maintenant en guerre et en première ligne
donc je n'y touche plus
poursuivre leur
tellement énervé
vous pouvez dire qu'il y a 2 000 ans n'était pas pour
les temps sont venus parce que les quais qu'ils étaient
prêt pour les prothèses meng cool & vif
sevka je t'ai ajouté maintenant au patient
siècle nous
soldats
amputations
familier, mais brièvement
épaule kuksa et
pliage à l'arc tse